okay thank you yeah so the title is
slightly different than the one in the
program so there's a cryptography is
turning to crypto land that was exactly
to make this point even more evident
that we're so in exactly so this is
joint work with with me here Volare and
eager Stepanov and yes when the work is
as metres just said is going to be about
showing relations about notions that are
centered around the notion of
obfuscation and you know when I talk
about crypto and really so what I mean I
you know summarizing I really mean this
you know the incredible and exciting
landscape of notions that cryptographers
have been considering over the last few
years and you know one of the thing
about all of these notions and
assumptions that we've been studying is
that they are very powerful but
something we were asking ourselves so we
should be asking ourselves is you know
how many of these assumptions or notions
are really true they really exist and
which ones are too good to be true right
and you know in a quest to like find a
good map of crypto land you know
something that we're really good in
doing is cryptographers and we're trying
to do is to exactly find relations among
different notions and find out what
implies what and what implies that
something else doesn't exist and you
know we had a lot of different results
already showing on the one hand
implications of the form a implies B so
showing that if something exists and we
can get a lot of exciting things out of
it so for example from IO or the IO and
so on but also there is a series of
exciting results that are equally
exciting results but even a little bit
more intriguing that show us things of
the type a implies not be so they show
that under the assumption that one of
these notion exists something else that
we want to have doesn't exist then we
get an important message out of this
result which is that we have such you
know couple of notions for which we know
that at most one of them can exist okay
so this is an important message that we
get out of it of course we have to be
very careful and see what it really says
and what are the restrictions but we get
you know an important message out of it
okay and this work is to be seen in this
context so we're going to study such
relations and you know the common
denominator of this this results of this
work
you know looking at notions of security
that somehow have something to do with
wanting to have security in present in
presence of some auxiliary random input
that in particular we I'm going to focus
in this talk on two notions
the first one is Xavier input point of
vocation or a IPO for short so this is a
security notion for point of the skaters
in the presence of auxiliary input and
I'm going to talk in particular about
one result that shows that visual gray
box office keishon and a IPO are
somewhat incompatible together so only
one of them can exist for some specific
construction of of skaters any
particularly kinetise construction of a
point of the skater and I'm also going
to talk about very briefly about
potential new assumption for having such
constructions and the second part of
this shortest second part of this talk
is going to be about the notion of you
sees or universal computational
extractors this is actually a security
notion for hash functions so it looks
like a different context but I'm going
to show that is inherently connected
with a IPO and I'm also going to talk
about new possibilities in that area
also using obfuscation okay so let me
start and we don't Fisk Asian I mean we
talked about it already quite a bit so
let me just briefly repeat that you know
by an octopus couture I really mean
Anaya grim and efficient diagram it's
randomized and takes a circuit and
transform city to another circuit C
prime that somehow should not leak
anything about the circuit C order then
it's input-output behavior and should do
this by preserving functionality so we
want correctness we want the circuit C
prime to be the same as C on all inputs
and of course we want C prime not to be
much larger than C and usually this
notion of not giving anything out about
C other than its input output behavior
has been historically first formalized
via the notion of it for blackbox
security which I'm not going to really
formalize here but if the key point
there has been that already early on in
even the seminal paper of barakatuh but
we learned that actually this notion is
too strong and if you want to achieve a
beautification for all circuits that's
impossible
and so people have historically done
they started looking at simpler classes
of circuits for which we
I hope to get vvb association or to get
strong security okay and the classical
example and it's kind of the simplest
function from which you might expect to
get something useful and at the same
time get vvv security has been point
functions okay so a point function is
really just you know a function or
respectively a circuit in this case
which has some special point call it K
star hard-coded into it and the function
is only one on that particular point K
star and on any other point it's zero
okay and we had indeed feasibility
results for VBB security office creation
of such point functions what in the
standard model and in the random Oracle
model and and so this is you know was
the first positive step in the era of
obfuscation but what I'm going to talk
about specifically in this talk now is
point of education security in the
context where we have some auxiliary
side information on the point K star
which is being of the scale and this was
considered already by Gavaskar in july
in their paper in 2005 but specifically
and they shot some issue with auxiliary
input but specifically here I want to
discuss particular security notion which
is an undistinguished ability based
notion for zero input point of
discussion which is so which is of zero
input point investigation which is our a
IPO which what it requires it's not a
simulation based notion so what it asked
for is that essentially formally I'm
going to formalize it in the next couple
of slides is that if you're given the
auxiliary input a which might be
correlated with some point K star you
cannot distinguish the obfuscation of
the point K star from the obfuscation of
another random point K prime which is
independent of K star and also
independent of a
right that's an excellent point which is
so of course that's exactly what I was
about to say so this is not something
that we can expect to be true for any a
and any key star because as you've
gained is saying if a is equal K star
there's no hope to get this okay so
formalizing it requires a little bit
more in particular we have to say for
which distribution of s and K stars this
is possible okay and so in the way that
this would do it was not any particular
I have to say that you know the I you
know I think the notion might have up
here implicit here and there but the
place I know where this has been
formalized like datas of work by baton
scheme Pinet from VCC 12 that use
explicit it is notion to build three
bands even large protocols but so what
you need to do here is you have coming
back to this you have to formalize for
which a in k-stars this is this is
possible at all okay and so in
particular what we do is we look at so
what I call an auxiliary information
generator which is really just a
randomized diagram that outputs a pair K
and a and what I want for security to be
even possible in the sense that I just
described is that we satisfy an
unpredictability notion meaning that for
any polynomial time predictor if I am
given give zero input it is hard to
guess the point K that I want to
obfuscate except with negligible
probability and then what a IPO calls
for because for indistinguishability
when I sample K is in with such an
unpredictable auxiliary information
generator namely we compare an
experiment where we are such a generator
X we sample a ka and we office K the
point function I K so it's one all UK we
got the corresponding circuit we give it
to a distinguisher together with your
zero information and we want to compare
this with some other world where you
know we're still sampling K we divert
auxiliary input but then when we are off
with skating the point function we just
office Kate the point function for a
point K prime which is sample uniformly
and independent from K okay and then we
give the actual physician and still give
the very information to the
distinguisher okay and we say that your
for skater is a IP of secure if no
polynomial time distinguish early can
you see
which the left-hand side from the
right-hand side okay so we don't have
really many candidates for IPO but
something which has been conjecture is
that bought your first Gator by kinetic
that I'm going to talk about in the next
slide and the original point function of
a skater by biotech we from 2005 and the
appropriate assumption are a IPO secure
okay and let me stress that if we kind
of relax the requirement on our existing
information generator then things can
actually be simpler to achieve so for
example if we actually assume that the
secret point K is exponentially hard to
guess even a then we can do things for
example by using the technique of
Dolly's car I love it and we can do that
but the highly serious that we want to
do things when K is really just protein
on really hard to guess do not
exponentially hard okay and so this is
pretty much the state of affairs and now
I want to spend a few more words about
for my first result about on kinetics
construction okay so so kinetic
construction is really the simplest
example of of a point of whoo skater and
you know it has been assumed to satisfy
different things in different contexts
that's a different assumption but the
piscator by itself realize in its
simplest form and i prime order group g
and what it does is in order to escape a
point function for some secret point k
what it does is it samples just a random
group element then it just computes call
it y then it just computes Y to the K
called this Z and then your first
question is and the actual office
question is a circuit that I call here C
Y Z which simply check given an input X
and this hard-coded Y Z whether Y to the
X is equal to Z okay that's very simple
okay
and clearly correctness is perfect right
so I mean if you have dolly dolly so if
this is a primary group so you know the
only value that can satisfy this is K
okay and security actually turns out to
be equivalent in essence to a variant of
the DDH assumption which I call AI DDH
okay yeah
for zero input which essentially states
that you know the DDH assumption holds
even if you're given some exhibit so if
you're if you're if you're if you have
some unpredictable of zero information
generator kna and you've got your K is
going to be your exponent so you're
given R R to the K and your auxiliary
input and you want is to be
computationally indistinguishable from
our our prime and a where R prime is
just some other random element which is
independent of our okay so if you don't
have the a and you choose K uniformly
this will be just equivalent to the
deviation sumption and here we just have
some additional auxiliary information
about that what's the distribution of a
so here you're just assuming that X as
this property so it could be anything
here as long as given a it is
computationally hard to predict a okay
right so it's a kind of a more compacted
down version where you can think of
distance GG to the are okay but the
point in tradition in the key point here
is not just the form but mostly the
under the key point is that in
traditional DDH you don't have gives in
your information about it okay so it's
definitely a much stronger assumption
okay and that's the key point okay so
you know so our first result is actually
about this AI DDH assumption okay and so
it states that if V GB holds and after
more about a second about V GB then the
AI DDH assumption cannot hold and so by
V GB I I'm gonna say explicitly in a
couple of slides what I need from V GB
rather than giving the whole definition
because it's actually simpler but so by
V GB I really mean virtual gray box
office keishon which was introduced and
started by Petoskey connecting 2010 and
so for what we know for V GB now is that
I know there's this also recent work by
Vuitton scale showing that you know
under appropriate assumption on multi
linear maps it
be achievable for all of NC 1 and we
don't know if you're struggling
possibility results but here I have to
stress that we only need a special case
of vgb in the proof ok specifically of
course if we should be for all circuits
is true then this theorem is true but
you're going to see in a second we
actually need less ok
any particular I have to stress that
it's not really just you know a break of
the assumption so if you're really
interested about the security of
kinetics point of ascator in 0 input
setting it's also a break of the
construction but it's easier to state it
for the case of the assumption ok ok so
and in particular the proof you know
that the structure of the proof is very
simple
ok so if you want to prove this what you
need to do is you need to give some
auxiliary information generator X which
you know for which it's easy you know to
see to break the assumption so give me
exhilaration but then you also want to
prove of course that is satisfied a
condiment reality condition meaning that
it's it is hard to guess k giving the
exact information a ok
and so how does it work I just want to
go through a high level of you know how
to do this so you know the auxiliary
information is really if you think about
it for a couple of minutes it's really
what you will expect it to be ok so your
generator is going to output some random
K which is kind of important because you
know you might want to debate whether
you want to believe the assumption for
case that have a lower entropy or not
but so for this counter example the K
can be really random and the observe
your information is going to consist of
the vgb of viscacha
so for now think of an obfuscation of a
circuit TK which has the secret value K
hard-coded in it and all it's going to
do it is going to take a PI a pair of
group elements y&z and then just check
if Y to the K is equal to Z ok and
obviously this is going to break our
assumption because given our Z and these
auxiliary information in form of the
circuit you just interpreted as a
circuit you run it on R and Z and then
you check whether the circuit outputs 1
and if Z is actually random you're
almost never gonna put one in otherwise
your voice output 1 so the key point is
actually proving that this is
unpredictable and that's where vgb comes
into play
so what we want to say now is that let's
say we have some fixed polynomial time
predictor P what we want to do now is we
want to prove that you know given a
sample from this distribution it must be
hard to guess K given the obfuscation of
the circuit DK and so to do this you
know let's just do the following ok and
I just want to map it back to you know
VG purification and so to do this I want
you to think of the following it so
imagine that we have now two just
sampling algorithms that are going to
spit out a circuit the first one is just
gonna output just the circuit TK I just
described for some random K and the
other one is just an algorithm that
doesn't really do much it always outputs
the constant of zero circuit okay now
imagine now that we look at this
experiment here where you know we just
output this circuit TK for a random K
with vgb off you scale it give it to
some adversary a that outputs a zero and
one and adversary a is just this simple
form okay it's going to just take the
circuit as input so in this particular
case the VG beautification of DK it's
going to run the predictor that we fixed
for which we want to prove that the
predicting advantage is readable and
I'll put a guess for the secret K Prime
and then what we're going to do is we
want to check whether these guess is
kind of correct or not we don't have
much we can use other than the circuit
which was input to a so what we're going
to do is we're going to take this C
Prime
we're gonna pick some element from the
group say randomly it doesn't really
matter actually how you pick it and
we're gonna just input to the circuit
that we are given Y and Y to the K prime
where K prime is the guess now of course
if we are in this word for real where C
prime is an obfuscation of decay the
probability that is adversary outputs 1
because our C prime is really decay it
is exactly the probability that our
predictor is correct okay but if we run
the same with you know the sample that
always offers your zero circuits then
what we get is that obviously the
probability that we output one year is
always 0 because there
no way you can output a 1 because C
prime is the constant 0 circuit ok
and so here it's where now vgb comes
into play okay so we want to show that
this probability is close to zero and so
it's negligible so what we do bigger
antes to us is and this is exactly what
we need here no more than this it
implies that there exists some simulator
s which doesn't need to be its vgb so it
can be unbounded which makes some
polynomial number of queries to an
Oracle and which satisfies a number of
things so in particular the first thing
the simulator guarantees is that if we
look at this experiment we just look
before with the adversary a and we look
at the probability that the adversary a
outputs one then and we compare this
with another experiment where the
simulator is going to just access as an
Oracle the circuit TK which is sample
for a random K and we compare the
probabilities that the simulator and
their adversary output 1 then these
probabilities are negligibly close but
at the same time the simulator also for
the same adversary also guarantees that
the probabilities of outputting 1 are
the same if we now move to the setting
where we are considering the search the
sampler that always outputs the all-0
circuit ok ok and we know that this is
this is 0 we know that these are close
so the only question that remains to
answer if you want to prove that this
probability is negligible is to answer
how close these two probabilities are
but that's easy ok because now we're
really asking to see you know what is
the difference between the probabilities
of simulator outputs 1 when interacting
with this circuit with the decayed
circuit for a hard-coded random K or
when interacting with all 0 circuits ok
and you see that the only way to do this
is that even though the simulator is
computationally unbonded is to make a
query such that the discrete log of of Z
to the base why's K ok but you know and
as long as you don't do that
you know you get no information about K
and you can actually information
theoretical bound this by something
which is negligible ok so that's why it
really doesn't matter here and we can
use the fact that the simulator might
even be computationally n Bob yeah so
this is the end of the proof and I have
to stress that it's not easy to you know
go under vgb so for example to use AI or
or something else so maybe it's not
immediately obvious but we really use
kind of inherently some property here of
vgb okay so just for the I want to spend
the last five minutes just mentioning
the thing about just what you see just
wrapping up about vgb I want to say that
of course there and and an a IPO so
there's alternatives to this
construction to connect this
construction for example the
construction by we has been conjectured
to be I feel secure but I just want to
point out and one needs to be very
careful first of all because if you use
the plain construction at the beginning
it was already shown in the work of
kvass wrinkle I to be insecure for
auxiliary input it's been extended to
work on with a family of permutations
rather than a single permutation in the
world by beaten ski epinet and they made
some assumption under which you will be
IPO secure and I just want to stress
that even though maybe things are less
clear therefore kinetics construction
the Assumption as suffer in some cases
from similar issues like what I just
shown so it's not clear that I wouldn't
put my bed there and so in the paper
yeah will be and that's exactly I mean I
should have stressed it more at the
beginning but it's exactly why this type
of result the important message that you
get out of here is about the contention
and not about the fact that I'm saying
it's impossible okay so it's impossible
under these assumptions but the message
you should take home is like you know
one of the two are most is true it might
well be that vgb is the problem okay so
what border Falls yeah yeah yeah
so the message you should take home is
that they're not both through at the
same time okay so that's the only thing
that we know for sure okay and then you
can make your own beliefs out of that
yeah
but be positive the incompatibility of
the two yeah yeah I might have ever use
your impossibility yes incompatibility
to change this okay sorry
that's an obviously where you're
confused yes okay yes okay so and I
wanted to just point out that you know
we just in the paper we have some a
longer discussion also which other
assumptions you know imply actually the
IPO more generically and I'm not don't
have time to discuss this yes I mean
depends on general your question is
right so for other problems you mean so
so this particular result here is Taylor
that at at at this particular IPO so it
can be generalized in a sense that if
constructions of certain properties then
you can see you can extend it but it's
specific to this to security property so
I guess you see yeah really well I guess
the time is running out but so so I want
to say for you see I mean let me try to
summarize that in the couple of minutes
that I have left so so one of the key
points here is a short relation between
a IPO and you see and so what is you see
I mean for those of you that are not
familiar so you see is really an
assumption about hash functions so by
itself it's not directly related to
alpha station and it's been proposed by
the Lariat how to as a notion to replace
random Oracle's in some construction be
laying around relying a random Oracle
and so one of the key points about you
sees is that there won't really be time
to discuss the notion too much but so
what you see what you see essentially
tries to formalize and formalize this is
the notion that you know in certain
context a certain hash function might be
indistinguishable from a random Oracle
and what is the way that this is
formalized is by having experiments
where we have a source that can either
access a hash function from a hash
family or access a random Oracle and
then provides
leakage to a distinguisher that knows
the actual hash function sample from the
family and the task of the distinguisher
is to distinguish in whether the source
was interacting with the random Oracle
or was interacting with the hash
function and the key point here is that
and of course you want to say that a
certain family of hash function is UC
secure for a certain source if no
distinguished I can tell apart and the
key point is that you can't really
achieve and we know that UC security for
all possible sources so for example if
you have a source that just query a
certain input and then just give you the
corresponding output and mix out the
input output pair therefore
distinguisher is very easy to figure out
whether you the source was interacting
with a hash function or with a random
Oracle okay and so skipping a couple of
slides here there's actually there's
been like very different classes of
sources that are being considered for
which people have looked at whether you
see is possible or not for a pour
concrete hash function and in particular
the landscape looks a little bit
complicated and and so there's you know
there's been you know this new classes
of sources these are computation sources
the computation on a statistical and
predictable sources so these are sources
for which it is exactly hard to for a
predictor to guess which queries the
source is making and as other classes
like splittable sources and you can also
restrict sources with respect to a many
queries they make to the to the actual
hash function that is being given and in
particular s1 will be the the set of
sources that only make one query and so
we have different results showing in
achievability
and in particular it's very easy to sort
of just said before to see that you
can't achieve security for all sources
that make only one query and there's
been some work showing by Brusco for
Sheen emitter back that showed that we
can't achieve UC security for sources
for which is only computationally hard
to to predict which queries the source
has been doing and somehow this is you
know this is kind of like create the
game where we try to see you know for
which sources we can also have security
and still find meaningful applications
and other
that we have in this work and I wanted
to stress here that all of this
impossibility is a really results of the
type you know showing that you know for
any hash function you can come up with
or existent source for which you can't
achieve you see security okay so in two
things we also show in this work and
this results are assuming yellow and two
things that we show in this work the
first of all is that we can actually
find actually other sources for which
you see security cannot be achieved that
satisfies all the properties including
split ability and I won't have time to
discuss this I only want to point out
that this result is actually quite
interesting because on the way we do
this by showing the impossibility under
a euro for certain type of stronger
leakage resilient encryption that we can
show how to achieve with as functions
that are you see secured for sources
that are in the intersection of this
classes but if you we keep that we can
prove impossible under IO but the more
interesting fact with respect to a IPO
is that if we actually look at uce for
sources that I have intersection of all
of these classes so we can actually
characterize and that's the key point
you have to take home so a class of
sources for UC security that turns out
to be essentially equivalent if IO
exists to a IP um okay so even though
we're actually looking here at security
for fetch functions in the context of
associating random Oracle's there is a
very tight connection between certain
type of UC securities that we are still
expecting to be possible for now because
they are not covered by existing
impossibility result and a IPO security
so the two notions are really I really
connected with each other okay and so
let me just conclude it's likely to run
out of time that I think you know the
main conclusion here is that you know in
this work we really try to explore this
landscape and I really only showed a
couple of examples of security notion
that somehow real I have this common
denominator of having their security
relying on some of your input and this
is an extremely tricky setting to
consider there are some non-obvious
resolve that excludes like like this
contention results using vgb but
you know we really found some
interesting connection between you see
and I hear they're sure that there's
some common factor that you know that
they all share and also reduce kind of
the set of things we can look at and
this leads us today I think the
challenge in open question which we
really don't answer but it seems that
you know very crucial open question is
to try to figure out whether a IPO is
possible at all I mean not all if you're
interested in the notion of in the
notion of obfuscation but also because
it's really also relevant in the context
of associating edge functions for random
Oracle secure schemes and you know it
would be a very valuable thing to
explore and we really only gave a very
you know partial indication here which
is exactly in this sense of this
contention result okay so that's all I
wanted to say a bit less than what I
wanted to say
you see yes no actually not so but I
think there was this sense that if you
just you know so the key point there is
that there was a sense that if you just
look at the intersection of splittable
sources and computational and
predictable sources there was no problem
with it but I think all applications
that I'm aware of they only require also
the source to make one query okay which
is really the center intersection and
for that we are still fine so the only
thing that we say additionally that
really that that ends up being
equivalent to an IPO but it's still fine
but you really also tells you that you
have to restrict to the number of
queries so you can't have arbitrary
number of queries of the sources but for
applications we they're fine with just
the source having unclear anything about
statistical unpredictable but there are
some application where you require
computational unpredictability and the
way we got around impossibility results
so far was exactly by you know getting
out of the part that was covered by the
possibility result by assuming split
ability and it so happens that the
results are fine with just one query to
the source and but if you allow multiple
queries that we have this impossibility